>> Sean: JOINING US NOW WITH
MORE REACTION TO TONIGHT'S
WATCH TOM FITTON.
SARAH CARTER, GREGG JARRETT.
TOM, WE ARE STILL MISSING 33,000
EMAILS.
THIS IS A COUPLE HUNDRED.
THERE WAS CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
THERE WAS CLASSIFIED INFORMATIO
INFORMATION.
I KNOW JUDICIAL WATCH WORKS VERY
HARD.
FREEDOM OF INFORMATION ACT.
WHAT DID YOU FIND?
>> IT'S A NEW BATCH OF EMAILS
FROM THE EMAILS JAMES COMEY'S
FBI RECOVERED, FROM THE EMAILS
AND HILLARY CLINTON TRIED TO
DELETE OR HIDE.
THIS IS THE BACHELOR CLINTON AND
HER LAWYERS DIDN'T WANT ANYONE
TO SEE AND THEY INCLUDE TEN
CLASSIFIED EMAILS ABOUT
MIDDLE EASTERN POLICY,
COMMUNICATIONS WITH ANTHONY
BLAIR, AND TOP OFFICIALS
AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT ABOUT
MIDDLE EASTERN PEACE.
ITS FURTHER INDICATION AND
FURTHER DEMONSTRATION OF A
MASSIVE VIOLATION OF NATIONAL
SECURITY LAWS RELATED TO
MISHANDLING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION THAT HILLARY CLINTON
KNOWINGLY ENGAGED IN.
WE ARE SPENDING ALL HIS TIME AND
MONEY TARGETING DONALD TRUMP ON
REALLY NOTHING AND IN THE
MEANTIME, HILLARY CLINTON HAS
WALKED AWAY SCOT-FREE DESPITE
TIME AFTER TIME OF NEW
INFORMATION COMING OUT SHOWING
SHE ENGAGED IN CRIMINAL CONDUCT.
THIS JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, THEY'VE
GOT TO DECIDE WHETHER THEY'RE
GOING TO LET JAMES COMEY HAVE
THE LAST WORD OR WHETHER
HILLARY CLINTON IS ANYTHING
WRONG OR NOT.
>> Sean: GREGG JARRETT, I KNOW
YOU'RE BEEN WRITING A BOOK, AND
YOUR OFFICE IS TWO DOORS DOWN
FOR MINE.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO TELL THE
TITLE BUT THEN I WANT YOU -- WE
ARE BACK AGAIN.
I FEEL LIKE I'M GETTING A LAW
EDUCATION FROM YOU.
18 USC 793 AND NOW IT'S
APPLICABLE TO JAMES COMEY
TONIGHT.
>> ABSOLUTELY IS.
THE NAME OF THE BOOK IS CALLED
"THE RUSSIAN HOAX."
THE ILLICIT SCHEME TO CLEAR
HILLARY CLINTON AND FRAME
DONALD TRUMP.
ONE OTHER THING THAT'S
INTERESTING THAT WE ARE LEARNING
ABOUT TODAY IS THAT COMEY
APPEARS TO HAVE COMMITTED A
FELONY BY MISLEADING CONGRESS, A
MATERIAL OMISSION BECAUSE COMEY
WAS ASKED ABOUT LEAKING THE
MATERIAL TO DANIEL RICHMAN.
HE DIDN'T DISCLOSE THAT RICHMAN
WAS AN FBI EMPLOYEE.
HE DIDN'T DISCLOSE THAT HE ALSO
GAVE IT TO PATRICK FITZGERALD,
BY THE WAY THE FBI HAS GONE TO
BOTH OF THOSE GENTLEMEN'S
OFFICES TO DO WHAT'S CALLED A
SPILLAGE CLEANUP TO CONTAIN THEW
SPILLAGE CLEANUP TO CONTAIN THEO
SPILLAGE CLEANUP TO CONTAIN THEG
SPILLAGE CLEANUP TO CONTAIN THEU
SPILLAGE CLEANUP TO CONTAIN THEL
SPILLAGE CLEANUP TO CONTAIN THEA
SPILLAGE CLEANUP TO CONTAIN THE
SPILLAGE CLEANUP TO CONTAIN THEY
SPILLAGE CLEANUP TO CONTAIN THEC
SPILLAGE CLEANUP TO CONTAIN THEM
SPILLAGE CLEANUP TO CONTAIN THEY
SPILLAGE CLEANUP TO CONTAIN THE.
THE OTHER THING, AND COMEY'S
COMMENTS HE MADE TONIGHT, HE
SEEMS TO BE OVERLOOKING THE FACT
THAT HE STOLE GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS.
18 USC 641.
THE MOMENT HE TOOK THOSE
PRESIDENTIAL MEMOS OUT OF THE
FBI BUILDING AND TOOK THEM HOME,
DOESN'T MATTER IF IT'S IN HIS
SAFE.
IT'S AN UNAUTHORIZED PLACE.
HE WAS STEALING GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS, WHICH IS A FELONY.
>> Sean: ALL FOUR OF US HAVE
BEEN WAY AHEAD OF THE CURVE.
I WAS JOKING TONIGHT THAT IT
SOUNDS LIKE WITH A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ANDERSON COOPER ASKED
JAMES COMEY, HE MIGHT'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN WATCHING THE SHOW
I'M NOT TELLING ANYBODY BECAUSE
THEY HAVE BEEN ON THE WRONG PATH
FOR A LONG TIME OVER THERE.
BUT YOU KNOW, SARA, WE ARE
WAITING THE STRZOK-PAGE MEMOS.
I WANT COMMENTS ON THAT END
THIS.
ANDREW MCCABE IS IN TROUBLE.
JAMES COMEY IS IN TROUBLE.
STRZOK AND PAIGE ARE IN TROUBLE.
HILLARY CLINTON IS IN TROUBLE.
I MEAN, THIS GOES TO, AND I DO
BELIEVE CLAPPER AND BRENNAN.
I WANT TO FIND OUT WHAT THEY
KNEW, WHEN THEY KNEW IT AND THE
LEAKING INTELLIGENCE AND
SURVEILLANCE AND UNMASKING.
WE ARE AT THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG
AND IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
>> WE ARE AT THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS ANOTHER
REPORT COMING OUT IN MAY.
THAT REPORT WILL DETAIL HOW THE
FBI HANDLED, MISHANDLED THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION AND LET'S
GO TO THE STRZOK AND PAGE TEXT
MESSAGES.
WHY IS IT THAT CONGRESS HAS TO
MAKE THREATS, THREATS OF
CONTEMPT IN ORDER TO GET THESE
DOCUMENTS?
THEY HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT THESE
DOCUMENTS FOR SOME TIME NOW.
TURN THEM OVER TO CONGRESS.
LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE WHAT
THEY HAVE.
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAS.
I KNOW I HAVE REPEATEDLY CALLED
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TODAY.
I RECEIVED NO CALL BACK, NO
INFORMATION WAS OVER.
AS TO WHY THEY HAVE NOT TURNED
HIS OVERGROWN ANOTHER
CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS SAY THEY
ARE EXPECTING TO GET THEM
TOMORROW.
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF CONCERN
HERE WITH COMEY.
COMEY CAN TRY TO BACKTRACK AND
MAKE THESE EXCUSES BUT HE DID
TAKE FBI PROPERTY OUT OF THE
FBI.
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT COMEY IS
REALLY GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH IS LIKE, IF HE BELIEVES
THAT HIS DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
PRESIDENT WERE UNCOMFORTABLE,
WERE OBSTRUCTION, WHY DIDN'T YOU
TELL CONGRESS THIS WHEN HE SPOKE
TO THEM ON MAY 3.
WHY THE RUNAROUND?
WHY THE LEAKING?
>> Sean: AGAIN WE ARE BACK
BACK TO LYING BY OMISSION.
SORT OF WITH THE FISA COURT
APPLICATION.
THEY KNEW THEY DIDN'T VERIFY IT
AND THEY KNEW THEY HANDED IT
OVER, THEY HANDED OVER SOMETHING
THAT WAS SOMETHING MORE THAN
POLITICALLY TAINTED.
IT WAS AN OPPOSITION PARTY
CANDIDATE.
I WANT TO ASK ALL OF YOU THE
SAME QUESTION.
WE WILL START WITH TOM.
WHO, BASED ON WHERE WE ARE
TONIGHT, WE KNOW NOW COMEY IS
LAWYERED UP.
WHO ALL SHOULD BE LAWYERED UP
TONIGHT?
TOM FITTON.
>> ANDREW MCCABE OBVIOUSLY.
THIS A REFERRAL PENDING NOW WITH
THE U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA.
THAT COULD COME AT ANY TIME.
MR. COMEY, I WOULD STOP GIVING
INTERVIEWS IF I WERE MR. COMEY
AT THIS POINT.
THE IG IS INVESTIGATING HIM, AND
WE ALREADY KNOW --
>> Sean: WE HAVE TO GO QUICK.
>> THE PROSECUTORS ARE WAITING.
COMEY AND McCABE FACED
SIGNIFICANT CRIMINAL LIABILITY.